this marks a significant day
in the history of this state
particularly so for survivors
and their families i understand just
how much the production of this report
has been the cause
of both anticipation and apprehension
for so many of you the minister and i
met with survivors online earlier today
to brief them on the final report and
the government's response
the report describes a dark difficult
and shameful chapter of very recent
irish history
and a history that has had a very real
and lasting consequences
for many people it holds up a mirror
to aspects of our past which are painful
and difficult and from the present-day
perspective
often hard to comprehend
the testimony of survivors set up by the
commission in their confidential report
makes often harrowing reading and i
appreciate the depth of bravery
of the survivors who shared their
experiences
it opens a window onto a deeply
misogynistic culture in ireland over
several decades with serious and
systematic discrimination
against women especially those
who gave birth outside marriage
while this report will obviously have
the most direct impact on survivors and
their families
it presents all of irish society with
profound
questions the regime described in the
report
wasn't imposed on us by any foreign
power
we did this to ourselves as a society
we treated women exceptionally badly
we treated children exceptionally badly
we had a completely warped attitude to
sexuality
and intimacy and young mothers and their
sons and daughters
were forced to pay a terrible price for
that dysfunction